are you having fun there I'm having a
blast oh and I figure out I figure I've
had it I'm trying to figure out your
pattern stops car with my G phone huh I
said stop stop screw with my g phone
whoa I'm just trying to find the right
spot on your new phone you're never
gonna find my g-spot I'll give you a
hint it has something to do with me so
it's one-dimensional Oh since you're so
much smarter than I am why don't you
figure out Joe's unlock code I can't a J
oh that's incredible anyway right now
we've got the google phone the t-mobile
g1 the CG one the G mobile t-mobile is
the first company to have a Google
Android native phone android is google's
new phone operating system and they've
used a telephone by HTC to make it
happen I don't really love the hardware
of this phone it has this little curve
in it which is it's stupid and when it's
in your pocket it just it's
uncomfortable ok so I really don't like
that it's got a little track ball in
there but it's also a touch screen so
you can you know move stuff around it
actually has a three panel display kind
of like the iphone does except the
iphone has a variable number of panels
and this one has actually three only
button you know you customize it kick
the screen up with this interesting
little dancing hinge so it's sort of an
arc hinge and the reason they do that is
because they keep most of the hinge
machinery inside of the phone so you can
actually expose more of the keypad and
I'm happening right there yeah and it's
stupid bendy bit which also houses your
microSD card slot here's my concern
about this this this piece of artwork
that you have so no time with i have
spent very little thought the hell is he
doing here anyway pointless in your corn
flakes this morning android is an
interesting operating system it works a
lot like your pc has a single click and
an effective right click which is
actually just a long tap so if you do so
basically when your when your long
tapping like that it brings right that's
basically right clicking on your brings
up a contextual menu just like with the
iphone it has an app store here they
call it the marketplace
means app store in google phones right
currently everything in the marketplace
is free because Google hasn't yet
implemented a payment system which is
great because like I said everything's
free so i've downloaded pretty much
anything looks remotely interested i
have a skype client by a company called
I scoot I got a really useless fractal
viewer and then my favorite useless
application seismograph so you put this
on here and it uses the phone's
accelerometers to actually do a
seismograph so oh look at nine on the
Richter scale I was at a nine it was
nearly we gave it a five okay here we go
that one was a nine what do I have it
keep it plugged in and wait for an
earthquake ah so like I said we have
some useless applications but then
there's some really useful ones like the
barcode scanner so use take a product
was like stop right there for example
space cowboys starring Dennis Hopper no
no well you're Clint Eastwood Donald
Sutherland James Garner and Tommy Lee
Jones and Tommy Wiggins I meant for how
many of these actors resist their last
movie so you go in and then you use the
barcode scanner need you basically put
this let the camera see the barcode it
got it it says found product then you
just go to open product search and it
automatically takes you to Google
Product Search and finds you the best
price so it goes to do so there's an
actual website called Google Product
Search yeah and it'll find the best
price for the for the space cowboys DVD
yes Google is an information searching
so I know you can use to find
pornography yeah and then you and then
can do other things apparently and
anyway like I said what is he doing here
space cowboys which are available for as
little as ten cents all right how much
is shipping and handling I don't know we
can buy it later Danny okay but you can
actually borrow this one tonight yeah no
androids not an operating system for
somebody who wants a super easy super
fun phone I have to say you know iphone
still is king of that like symbian it's
fully open unlike symbian it's also
really easy to use so how much does this
guy cause this is a hundred and
seventeen dollars with a with a two-year
contract from t-mobile this is not going
to be just to be clear the only phone
that uses an
droid you're going to see a lot of them
pop up in the future it is the first
phone to use android which is what g1
after 90 days so they have to let you
unlock it it's how t mobile works and so
you can actually unlock this phone and
put it on AT&T it'll still work with
their network it is a 3g phone so it
gets high speed downloads I've gotten
around 600 kbps down which is bad it's a
little slower than AT&T network but give
t-mobile credit two months ago they
didn't have a 3g network now I've got 3g
by my house there's 3g New York and in
major markets I think they're gonna have
more than 20 major markets by the end of
the year which is which is pretty good
for somebody who's an urban phone user
obviously you have to have a mute music
capability for phone right now in order
to really get otherwise that really a
phone it's more of a piece of crap yeah
it makes home cost otherwise like to do
is call people with yeah I don't want
that no this one does have a really cool
function which is it has a direct link
to an amazon mp3 store where you can
download drm for you tracks that's
awesome so just like itunes but not
itunes and what kind of music heavy dela
daddy you have it giving you tag on it
actually yeah I do all right nonsense
unfortunately if you look at this phone
there is no headphone jack what the f
HTC so we've got this right there we got
this HTC standard mini-usb use our
crappy headphone jack and not even they
don't even come with an adapter so you
can put your own headphones and do it
that make me angry make Joanne Joe mad
yeah joe mad smash and it's not my phone
Joe get smashed maybe that's more like
that's more realistic does do cut and
paste it does do cut and paste holla ah
does does new compass I really think
that nobody could come up with a new
mobile operating system Falcon page with
all the attention Apple his head has
gotten
they've they've gotten a lot of flack
they've gotten a lot of flat that's
unfortunate where my damn cut and paste
where'd that come from all right scan me
tell me how much I'm worth I'm gonna
give this phone a 7 out of 10 but the
phone itself i'm giving a 6 i'm getting
an 82 the operating system because
that's almost as much of a noteworthy
products is the phone itself so the
average amount we're gonna get a 787
blue ball this little flashlight is the
future actually it's not nobody's ever
gonna buy this to four hundred dollar
fetish flashlight from a company called
lumen craft and it's called the gat
light but in one way it is kind of the
future because it uses LED lighting to
produce an incredibly bright light I
don't know what's going to happen if I
flash this at the screen but uses LED
technology to produce an incredibly
bright light this is 250 lumens it's
about the brightest flashlight I've ever
seen is blindingly bright in fact they
say that if you're in a dark alley at
night and you get surprised by somebody
you might consider just flashing this in
your eyes as a form of self-defense I'm
not sure that flashing a
four-hundred-dollar flashlight in
somebody's eyes is necessarily going to
be all that effective at getting them to
not take your wallet it might just take
the flashlight instead but so be it it
has some nifty features in addition to
being designed out of incredibly cool
bits of titanium there are over 85
pieces in their hand laid by Swiss
watchmakers or something like that I've
got a really nice dial here for
adjusting the intensity of the light so
you can make it brighter or darker if
four hundred dollars is a little bit too
rich for your blood but you still want a
super bright LED light duracell has just
come out with a new line of their own
LED flashlights that called the daylight
series and this particular one uses a
lithium battery to generate with an LED
light 160 lumens of brightness which is
also incredibly bright in fact if I
hadn't seen the GATT light this would
have been the brightest flashlight I've
ever seen and this one is only 35 bucks
which is pretty good you can probably
get it at your local drugstore and it
even looks a little bit like a Duracell
battery so you be the judge
five dollars or four hundred dollars
you